it's extremely important to see a dog
and his wars behavior
Cesar confronts Willie by lifting up the
chair so when I confronted him he starts
showing fear so he was coming from a
fearful point of view so he was more
concerned about releasing his
frustration in the couch then releasing
his frustration on me Cesar needs Maya
to play a role in Willie's
rehabilitation but he also wants to make
sure she can't run away it's a more
neurotic behavior than anything else
very good girl controlling a larger
breed like a hundred five hundred fifty
pound dog it's easier they're gonna turn
a little dog because they're built to go
on their things so I needed my two hands
to block Willie from you know from
intensifying himself in this neurotic
behavior so I tied Maya to a lock that
was there available so she can
participate because I needed her silence
you know her energy if I didn't want her
to become like him I want her to become
like me
[Music]
I was treating him as an aggressive dog
and I was trying to block him and you
know help him to see a different state
as the cat would have done the cat was
definitely the pack leader the cat will
totally remind Willie what the rules the
boundaries and the limitations were and
Susan and Michael that just slept it
away and failed I believe bad about the
cat passing by and then they feel bad so
that can lead any dog to you know
insecurity nervousness anxiety does one
start seeing the rest of the eldest side
effects the only thing I'm doing is
claiming and as you see I'm not using my
hand because you already target the
hands at the moment that he's not on the
on the object that he's possessing
that's when you stop so he knows okay
what is it what they what is it they
want because he's in a possessive state
the only thing I want is you not to
possess this couch so at that moment you
stop so he gets he's get him so what
they want me to do is just to give them
the couch away yeah so at the moment
that I'm doing this as showing no fear
is just calmness
he's fear base you know this is not a
dog that is naturally aggressive
something make him afraid and then he
went under this thing and that he
learned to release his fear own this one
other big AHA was the fear base versus
aggressive behavior that as Cesar was
working with him and his worst behavior
under the chair Cesar said this dog is
an aggressive he's afraid and I don't
know what it came from it you know he's
he's really afraid of fire
and thunder and it could have been
something like back to that
[Music]
[Applause]